on en vient maintenant elles se
rapportent d'amnesty international
publié aujourd'hui le concert des
exactions commises par des forces de
sécurité sur des populations civiles
orange et à recenser 199 incidents
commis par ses forces de sécurité entre
février et avril à 2020 142 disparitions
forcées 57 exécutions extrajudiciaires
des actes imputés aux soldats maliens
nigériens et burkinabè à slash elle
s'ajoute c'est vrai d'insécurité liée
aux actes jihadistes des enquêtes ont
été ouvertes dans la région pour
apporter toute la lumière sur certaines
affaires on va justement en parler avec
sadie au moral quand tu es journaliste
spécialiste de la fecq
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord comment
vous vous accueillez ce document
d'amnesty international alors que l'on
sait que au sahel
c'est vrai que l'opération bar canal est
plutôt commence à être de plus en plus
mal vu par les populations locales
alors il faut dire que ils auront tort
de voir de mal voir une fois je lave ou
l'opération à canon parce que le sommet
de pau a été magnifique conte sera qu'
il s'est focalisé là mais tous feux sur
la zone des trois frontières burkina
niger mali où siège la base de l'état
islamique
donc c'est une zone que les tests avec a
voulu qu'on caire et s'est fortement
positionné donc le fait de mettre tout
fait sur cette zone à démanteler le
réseau qui cherchent à s'installer et à
avoir plus de positionnement sur le
territoire et ça fait que depuis le
temps où l'état islamique et al qaïda
était en symbiose dans le sahel pour la
première fois donc depuis le début de
l'année on a vu qu'ils sont en train de
s'entre déchirer pour la reconquête
justement des territoires de ce fait qui
est des exactions et je crois que il
faut voir plusieurs facettes de cette
exaction exactions de ces exactions
parce que la situation est très complexe
n'oubliez pas que dans un premier temps
il y a
le captiva de amadou fall qui a utilisé
les peuls et qui ont eu des conflits
communautaires avec les dogons ce qu'est
actu a causé beaucoup de tueries il ya
eu des méfiances qui se sont installées
et ensuite les armes et recrutent
massivement un peu tout le monde et
n'importe qui parmi lesquels à des
confrères sur dont les produits que nous
avons tous ils n'ont pas manqué
d'attirer l'attention sur le fait que à
ses policiers ces soldats qui tue dans
les zones où ils devraient être
protecteur peuvent être des djihadistes
infiltrés dans les armées locales
donc je crois qu'il faut tenir compte de
cet aspect pour expliquer que dans cette
zone du sahel où la cosmogonie et
locales et que la vie est sacrée
on note pas la vie gratuitement que des
soldats en mission s'en prennent à des
gens oui ça peut être par méfiance pour
les peules utilisé par un amadou koufa
mais aussi à part des infiltrés des
factions djihadistes regrouper ou et
chapeauté par iliad a gagné le touareg
maliens qui appelait son mouvement
groupement islamique un groupement de
soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans donc
kirkout de part et d'autre est de plus
en plus massivement
donc ceux qui n'auront pas à ceux qui
auront perdu leur maître par des combats
parce qu'on n'oublie pas que la france à
a quand même thuillet voudrait que la
dernière fois c'est il ya quelques jours
là donc même les thèses mm arena où la
grille qui est mis à mal
donc ce sont des soldats qui se cherche
et qui peuvent être utilisés comme
agents à infiltrer pour commettre des
actions des exactions étant donné que
dans un village on a appris que les
poulets soldats qui ont tué 1 était non
identifié mais ça pose aussi des
questions sur l'efficience des désarmé
en afrique ça c'est une vraie question
aussi on se souvient qu'à l'époque de
l'opération 100 garris pour prendre cet
exemple en centrafrique il ya eu aussi
des exactions commis par des soldats
afri-can des soldats français aussi en
république centrafricaine oui on se
souvient de cet épisode où descendra des
soldats français ont été pris pour des
viols sur des enfants et que des soldats
un contingent de 120 soldats congolais a
été rapatriée sur le congo brazza pour
les mêmes faits oui il s'avère aussi que
quand les soldats arrivent il faut
savoir que sous payés ou mal formés et
peuvent commettre des exactions
le rapport d'amnesty international
d'ailleurs notre que ce sont des soldats
qui ne sont pas formés et qui face à la
suspicion souvent ouvrent le feu
ce n'est pas inclure donc là dessus il
faudrait à mon avis qui est un package
formation et recrutement et formation ce
qui est nécessaire et voir en amont
combien de gamme ces soldats qui osent
mettre leur vie en danger pour se
couvrir la population pour que tous
puissent se passait bien mais à ne pas
exclure que ils doivent ceux qui ont
commis des exactions doivent être
traqués et qui répondent de leur fais
quoi parce que vous ne pas tenir compte
de l'état de droit et serait une gravité
dans ce cas là justement la question
d'internet et c'est important puisque
les ong demandent à aux pays concernés
de mener des investigations
oui bien sûr bon vous avez vu que dans
la frontière burkina côte d'ivoire où
sévissent aussi une poste de djihadistes
depuis quelques temps à 1 un chef
d'escadron a été démis de ses fonctions
il sera élu c'est justement pour avoir
moucharder parce que il a il a parlé il
a trop parlé du au point qu' il ya une
traque qui devrait être mené dans la
zone frontière burkina côte d'ivoire a
les jihadistes ont pu s'enfuir et que la
traque n'a pas pu lieu où le
démantèlement du réseau n'a pas eu lieu
donc je pense que les états sont
conscients que quand il ya des bavures
de ce genre qui a des écarts de ce genre
il faut prendre des mesures juridiques
nécessaires pour que cela ne recommence
pas
le but étant de d'abord protéger les
vies des civils
merci beaucoup à vous ça
juraj quand et je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de la frite